دب ماما تمشي على جدار الفناء الخلفي
مع اثنين من أشبالها
عندما اندفع كلاب صاحب المنزل الثلاثة
نحوها ، حيث قام الدب في محاولة لحماية
أطفالها
بالتقاط أحد الكلاب من سترته ،
ثم شاهد هالي مارينيكو يندفع
نحو الدب
ويدفعها بعيدًا عن  ليدج الآن
شاهد الفيديو مرة أخرى مع العلم أن هايلي
يبلغ من العمر 17 عامًا فقط في تلك اللحظة ،
ليس لدي الكثير من الوقت لأفكر في الركض إلى
الدب وأول شيء أعتقد أنني أفعله هو
دفع الدب بعيدًا عن الحافة التي
يقف عليها
وهكذا آمل أن يطلق كلبي
،
وبطريقة ما الحمد لله ، إنه يعمل هايلي ثم
يلتقط
كلابها ويركض داخل ما كان يدور في
ذهنك عندما كنت
وجهاً لوجه مع هذا الدب بصراحة
، الشيء الوحيد الذي كان يدور في ذهني هو
الحماية
كلابي وهذا ما فعلته ، يمكن سماع والدي هاي المحمومة
وهم يصرخون عليها
في الخلفية ،
إنه لأمر مرعب أن ترى ابنتك
تقترب
من دب ضخم وتفكر فقط في أن
الدب كان بإمكانه
الضرب على وجهها
وسنواجهها  نوع آخر من الأخبار اليوم
يقول خبراء الحياة البرية أن الدب كان
يحاول ببساطة حماية أشبالها في
كاليفورنيا ليس لديها سوى الدببة السوداء الأمريكية
وهي ليست عدوانية بطبيعتها
تجاه البشر أو حيواناتنا الأليفة ،
فقد كانت تتفاعل مع التهديد المتصور
للكلاب وإذا كان هذا الحيوان  عدوانية بطبيعتها ،
من المحتمل أن
تتعرض تلك الكلاب للهجوم
بدلاً من الضرب فقط ، لا تدفع
الدببة لا تقترب
من الدببة ، فأنت لا تريد أن تصبح سيئ الحظ ،
لقد خرجت سالماً